ever wonder what extreme lengths your
favorite actors had to go to for a role
acting may look easy but many actors
have put themselves through a lot for
their characters
for example did you know that kate
winslet had to learn to hold her breath
for
over seven minutes it's safe to say that
acting requires
more than just looking good on camera i
don't know if i'd go through
this one again in an interview with gq
jacob belordy shared that he had to
learn how to ride a motorcycle for his
role
in the kissing booth he said while
shooting in south africa he was
basically thrown onto a motorcycle on
the side of a freeway
and was told to just figure it out he
said he fell a lot but
it was an awesome experience i don't
ride them my mum won't let me
in order to convincingly play olympic
figure skater tanya harding
margot trained for three months prior to
shooting she worked with skating
choreographer sarah kawahara
training about four times a week
starting completely from scratch
margo learned to spin a little bit
they started out with stretching then
practiced choreography on the floor
and eventually moving to the ice getting
on the ice i was like
i'm gonna break something and if i break
something i'm doing the maths in my head
i'm like it would cost us
how much robert pattinson's upcoming
version of batman has the actor working
under a grueling training regimen
it's required him to train in various
forms of martial arts
and he's becoming pretty skilled in
jiu-jitsu it's been reported that we
will get to see his version
of batman as a full force fighting
machine
and that robert has really been putting
the work in
gal gadot's training for wonder woman
required her to train
six hours a day six months before
shooting began
it was two hours of gym work two hours
of fight choreography and one and a half
to two hours
learning how to horseback ride she was
genuinely surprised at how painful it
was learning how to ride horseback and
she has a new respect for those who do
it regularly
i've learned how to fight with swords
horseback riding which is very
challenging
and a lot of hours in the gym in an
interview with us today
timothy shared that he spent about a
month and a half training to sword fight
and ride horses
while wearing the incredibly heavy armor
he would be wearing in the film
he said it was to get him into a place
that he looked like he could
convincingly
hold his own in a battle you try to get
good on the horse too
try to get good on a horse while
wielding a sword that kind of thing
in an interview with seth meyers ansel
revealed that he took about 10 stunt
driving classes in preparation for his
role as baby
he said he was able to do most of the
stunts after taking the classes but
while filming with his co-stars jamie
foxx and jon hamm
he wasn't allowed to drive he was
allowed to do some of the stunts when it
was just him though
oh interesting yeah so they didn't want
to risk the whole cast
yeah just me just part of it yeah
in the upcoming avatar 2 kate plays a
water person
which requires her to perform scenes
underwater in an interview with the
hollywood reporter kate said i had to
learn how to free dive to play that role
in avatar
and that was just incredible my longest
breath hold was 7 minutes and 14 seconds
like crazy crazy stuff madeleine has
aquaphobia
which is a fear of natural bodies of
water that made shooting her scene of
falling through the ice in season one
incredibly difficult she said that the
tank she was in for shooting was so deep
she couldn't see the bottom or the scuba
divers in the corner ready to jump in if
something happened
[Music]
jennifer said she loved her trainer and
she was incredibly strict
she said if i had a bad form she would
pinch my ear
she really didn't put up with anything
jennifer revealed that the training
permanently changed her bodies
my shoulders were two inches broader and
my right arm is one inch longer than my
left arm
the arrows weighed like two pounds right
i would like aim and look all cool and
then i'd shoot it and i'm just going
poop yifei leo was already an
accomplished martial artist before
landing mulan
but she still had to undergo six to
seven hours of training a day for three
months before shooting
she became skilled in wushu which is a
contemporary form of chinese martial
arts
cinematographer mandy walker said she
did 90
of her own stunts in the movie i wanted
to see
how much more i can do as an actress
while the actor isn't generally known as
a method actor he did learn how to make
the certain substance walter white was
famous for
he revealed on the graham norton show
that he spent time at the drug
enforcement agency where the chemist
there
showed him how to create the stuff he
said it was very interesting
intricate and dangerous and it's a
massive experience emotionally and
physically
joseph gordon-levitt actually had an
eight-day intense training session with
the person he was portraying in the walk
philippe petit before shooting
eventually he was able to walk across a
wire that was two feet off the ground
with ease
during his time with him he also learned
how to ride a unicycle
and to walk on his hands from fatigue
what i've learned is the balance comes
much
easier being in motion john went through
rigorous military-based training for his
role in 13 hours
in addition to spending countless hours
in the gym to get in shape he learned
several skills to make him feel like a
soldier
he had weapons training tactile training
and even learned how to maneuver through
a burning building
how many hours in the gym it was about
three to four hours a day for six days a
week and
yes yes it is there it is that is not
fake
leo went above and beyond for the
revenant including being close to death
several times
he had to sleep in animal carcasses go
in and out of freezing water
and eat raw animal meat including bison
liver
for the graphic bear fighting scene leo
said that it involved a lot of cables
and intense choreography yes it was
incredibly difficult to do
but you know we rehearsed for for weeks
beforehand on just that sequence
olivia went through extensive training
for her role in x-men
mainly learning sword fighting she
trained for five months
six hours a day learning how to
effortlessly and safely wield a katana
sword
it paid off because she ended up doing
95
of her own stunts in the film i've never
done sword work before and i started
doing
all the sword work and then wire and
stunt training
natalie portman spent eight hours a day
training as a ballerina for black swan
that paired with her extreme diet of
basically almonds and carrots
the oscar winner said she thought she
was going to die she even dislocated her
rib in rehearsals
but said that's not uncommon for
ballerinas to hurt themselves during the
process
i had to train a year before the film
so it it was great to sort of immerse
myself in everything
halle berry is now known as the best
female weapons handler in hollywood
due to her dedication for john wick in
preparation for the role she trained
with tar and tactical
she confessed that her training was the
hardest six to seven months of her life
she also became skilled in martial arts
and dog training
and even had three broken ribs during
that time i don't think she ever missed
a workout in the five months
since being cast in the new rocky creed
franchise michael b
jordan has spent years honing his boxing
skills even telling tmz
that he could hold his own against
former world champion roy jones jr
that definitely takes some guts but it's
impressive that michael has taken his
training for the franchise so seriously
the internet's boyfriend keanu reeves
actually had to learn how to surf for
point break
learning from the surf doctor of
hollywood dennis jarvis
dennis said that the training lasted for
about two months before shooting
and that all of the actors were pretty
much beginners keanu took such a shine
to surfing
that dennis made him his own custom
surfboard for personal use
for his role in fury shia labeouf joined
the national guard during the filming
process
spending a month living on a military
base while on the military base he
became a chaplain's assistant
he also went to extreme lengths outside
of the military training
he had a tooth fold and would cut a scar
into his face
after watching these actors push their
limits and train for months
we are truly impressed by the dedication
they have to their craft having to look
like a master of these insane skills
while being fully in character is
clearly what sets these actors in a
class of their own
learning a new skill or hobby is hard
enough let alone with a whole cast crew
and
studio watching to make sure you nail it
this definitely
makes us want to re-watch all of these
movies now